como presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro
está a la cabeza de uno de los países
más biodiversos del planeta y justamente
el tema de la protección de dicha
biodiversidad es uno de los que más
críticas le vale la minería dentro de
las áreas de conservación creció un 300
por ciento en todo el país y casi un 500
por ciento dentro de hechuras indígenas
con una aceleración estos últimos años
según más idiomas una investigación en
la que colaboraron una red de ong
universidades y empresas de tecnología
usted no son dentales duggan observamos
a un daño irreversible al medio ambiente
como consecuencia de la minería ilegal
de hecho es muy difícil que la
naturaleza se recupere de ello incluso
con la intervención humana también el
mercurio que se utiliza la extracción
trae consigo otros problemas de salud
pública especialmente para quienes viven
en las orillas del río y en la población
indígena mason es gp niños y poblaciones
indígenas los mineros dicen no tener
otras formas de ingresos y depositan
todas sus esperanzas un proyecto de ley
que el presidente evolucionado mandó al
congreso para abrir las reservas
indígenas a la minería comercial que no
hay empleos de 500 no hay buenas
empresas dentro del estado para que la
semana pasada miles de indígenas
acamparon en brasilia en protesta por lo
que consideran la agenda indígena del
presidente y marcharon hacia el tribunal
supremo que está analizando actualmente
un caso clave sobre sus derechos a sus
tierras ancestrales
además tras la llegada de bolsonaro al
poder brasil ha registrado el mayor
ritmo de deforestación de los últimos 13
años